- Health officials in
California are warning people
to stay away from
so-called measles party.
The get-togethers
are meant for parents
to intentionally expose
kids to the disease
to develop a natural immunity.
- Measles parties, guys!
(audience boos)
- Yeah, you don't
get to participate in
the liberal society!
- Lemme...I used to
hate it when, you know
when you have a birthday
party for your kid,
and you have to make the
party favors for everybody.
(panelists laugh)
And I'm like, he's the
birthday kid, give him...
and so now the party
favor is measles?
(audience laughs)
That's their version
of a plus-size model!
- I mean, that lady was
plus size from here to here.
(audience and panelists laugh)
I mean, the only thing
plus about her was here.
- [Host] Is it odd that a
few weeks after you move
into the neighborhood, Jon
Stewart decides he wants
to move out?
(audience laughs)
I would say that yes, it is odd.
I've said all along
that Jon is a racist.
(audience laughs)
Hey, America.
Larry Wilmore here.
If you like The Nightly
Show on Comedy Central,
like us on Facebook too.
Just don't poke me. I
do not like being poked.
You can Candy Crush me.